be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos rice playing things outside
of comic books so with Warner Brothers
announcing a Booster Gold Blue Beetle
team-up I figured this would be an
excellent time to make videos on these
characters and so what I'm going to do
here is a 101 over why it was a Booster
Gold was made transition to his origin
and round things out to where he
currently stands in the new 52 also for
those of you who are curious as to why
we're not doing an anime or a Dragon
Ball Z video today you can find that
video over at Rob explains
so Booster Gold was created by Dan
Jorgenson first appeared in his
self-titled series in 1986 as part of
DC's relaunch following the crisis on
Infinite Earths in an interview with
only nerds allowed calm a website
focusing on all things geek culture dan
Jergens had stated that his inspiration
for Booster Gold actually came from
several different sources because of
1980s were time when cable television
was becoming prominent allowing for a
larger network of television programs
for the home the commercialism that came
with this expansion coupled with Dan
Jergens overhearing a discussion
regarding an Olympian signing an
endorsement deal led to the idea of
breaking away from the traditional model
of super hero and trying something new
from the time Superman was first
introduced leading up to the 1980s while
his creation had established a superhero
archetype as a decades past and society
began to change this evolution allowed
for the introduction of various types of
superheroes while individuals like Dick
Grayson spider-man and Wolverine
provided variances in their characters
like comedy or an antihero edge and the
end the constant theme was a recognition
of something greater than themselves for
Dick Grayson it was the recognition that
his role as Batman's sidekick was just
as much about avenging his parents
murders as it was about preventing
others from experiencing the same loss
for spider-man it was about power and
responsibility and for Wolverine it was
the attempt at self-discovery breaking
away from this tradition dan Jergens
wanted to create a character that was
inspired to become a hero by way of
other superheroes but would go on to
become a reflection of commercialism by
effectively being a celebrity covered in
secret origins a series of publications
from DC would serve to provide the
origin stories of various characters in
a condensed form at issue number 35
served to maintain the theme of secret
origins but also retcon the information
provided in Booster Gold number one as
we're told
boosters real name is Michael John
Carter and he was introduced in the 25th
century as a college football player at
Gotham University who was also a gifted
athlete faced with the issue of his
mother being diagnosed with a
degenerative disease the cost to provide
her the necessary treatment to rid her
of her illness was more than either
Booster Gold or his sister could afford
resorting to taking bribes in return for
intentionally throwing games booster
found himself in a quagmire and that
while he was only supposed to throw two
games his own
lawyers kept him for longer under the
threat of going to the police if he
refused to maintain the business
arrangement while the process of
throwing games continued after several
weeks booster was able to acquire the
money for his mother's operation but
found himself tumbling into the world of
gambling when he was eventually
discovered and arrested by the police we
learned that his father had previously
found himself in the same situation
leading to boosters mother disowning him
and booster himself being kicked out of
Gotham University in disgrace after
receiving probation but losing any
chance of attaining a college degree and
working in the field of sports booster
moved to Metropolis and secured a job as
a security guard in the superhero Museum
spinning his time on the job going
through and researching the heroes of
yesterday which included Superman and
Batman booster rationalized that because
he had been disowned by his family and
had no real reason to stay in the 25th
century he began to piecemeal and outfit
together using a suit from one of the
models that allowed for super-strength a
rigging it allowed for flight as well as
a bill that created force fields and
along with a robot named Skeets that
could function as a library of
information allowing booster to
integrate himself into the past use the
time machine to travel to the 20th
century wrapping around two issues
number eight and number nine titled the
time bridge following his arrival in the
20th century booster went by the name
gold star and said about exploring the
world around him however after learning
that the president had been kidnapped by
a shape-shifting villain named chiller
who operated as part of the 1000 a
criminal organization which was led by a
senator who saw world domination through
deception assassination in blackmail
booster was able to defeat chiller for
his efforts booster was awarded a medal
and in return became known as the hero
who saved the President of the United
States using this as a jumping-off
platform booster took advantage of his
fame to garner advertising gigs and
using the money he made launch gold star
Incorporated which served as a holding
company to consolidate his wealth into a
single location
so following booster gold's introduction
into DC Comics because he broke away
from the traditional model of
superheroes at the time and that his
focus was centered on money and fame
while he wasn't the most successful
character in DC's lineup falling short
of more well-known publications like
Batman Green Lantern and Superman
booster developed somewhat of a cult
following under Dan Jergens booster
maintained a solo series it lasted for
25 issues and dealt with his escapades
as a hero while the 1000 as his main
foes Dan Jergens had tried to use
characters like Superman as a way to
increase boosters popularity by having
them cross over with one another but
because those who were reading Booster
Gold weren't looking for what Superman
had to offer the idea ultimately failed
in response Dan Jergens also introduced
boosters sister as a time-traveling hero
using the name gold star as a way to
increase his popularity but because so
little was known about her other than
the fact that she was mentioned lightly
during his origin fans didn't really buy
into what she was selling and as a
result while she remained as a
background character in 1987 Booster
Gold solo series was cancelled due to
poor sales following this booster was
somewhat shuffled around and that when
DC launched Justice League International
in 1987 as a branch off of the Justice
League title that focused less on the
United States and focus more on
international efforts while volume 1
only lasted for around 25 issues during
this time Booster Gold and Blue Beetle
became a standout stars leading to a
series of extremely popular teams
between the two following the
cancellation of Justice League
International and a subsequent rollover
into the Justice League of America with
Keith Griffin staying on his rider
alongside John Mateus one of boosters
most notable roles came during the death
of Superman in 1992 when doomsday
awakened on earth and began a rampage
while engaging doomsday in battle Visser
had actually given doomsday his name in
reference to the hopelessness of their
situation and his belief that their end
was at hand and so following this while
booster maintained a presence throughout
DC Comics with events like 2005's
Infinite Crisis which served to correct
several continuity issues that remained
following crisis on
in 1985 as well as a green lantern
blackest night story which introduced a
Black Lantern Corps under neck rod who
reanimated to see superheroes and sought
to eliminate all life and emotion from
the universe in addition to brightest
day which functioned as a conclusion of
blackest night by the time 2007 came
around Booster Gold received a second
solo series under Dan Jergens which ran
for 47 issues leading up to DC's line
wide reboot in 2011 with a new 52
so following DC's relaunch other titles
during the new 52 event Booster Gold was
introduced without a solo series instead
he was brought back under Dan Jergens
with Justice League International while
the series only lasted for 12 issues the
title served as a prelude of sorts to
the events of convergence and Justice
League international issue number 12
booster was met with a version of
himself from an alternate reality who
worked for Argus the Advanced Research
Group uniting superhumans which provides
aid to superheroes by way of information
as this alternate version states
Wonder Woman a Superman cannot be
allowed to become a romantic couple and
that if they do it will result in
booster never being born although we're
not really told why failing to keep
Wonder Woman and Superman from becoming
romantically involved the alternate
version of Booster Gold disappears
followed shortly by the new 52 Booster
Gold
and so with convergence centered around
DC's relaunch of their multiverse by way
of the villain Brainiac capturing
timeline so two previously belonged to
realities that were eliminated over the
course of DC's publication history with
events like crisis on Infinite Earths
the appearance of the alternate Booster
Gold and is vanishing as well as a
vanishing of the new 52 Booster Gold
were revealed to be a ruse by Brainiac
and an effort to manipulate them into
revealing the location of the vanishing
point a place which exists outside of
space and time
because Brainiac was able to access this
place he was then able to initiate the
convergence event by using the vanishing
point to travel to other realities in
space and time capture them and place
them on the planet Tilos with the
alternate version of Booster Gold in the
process of dying due to his constant
time-travel his life was saved when he
merged with the timestream and became
the character known as wave rider using
his new abilities to control time while
the conversion event ends with DC
restoring all of their alternate
realities Waverider sends the new 52
Booster Gold back to the new 52
continuity now whether or not this will
lead into booster receiving his own solo
series as part of the new 52 is unknown
but as it stands right now with
convergence having ended and with the DC
Multiverse making its return Booster
Gold remains unseen following its
conclusion with that being said we're
going to bring this video to an end I
hope you guys enjoyed it and I will
catch you guys later
whose